McDONALD'S IS GETTING THE GANG
BACK TOGETHER FOR A NEW AD
CAMPAIGN.
>> OH, TOTALLY.
THIS IS GONNA BE SO FUN.
HEY, HAS ANYONE SEEN GRIMACE?
>> NO, BUT IF I KNOW HIM, HE'S
SCARFING DOWN A COUPLE PREGAME
BURGERS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HEY, PROBABLY MORE THAN A
COUPLE, HUH?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HI, EVERYONE.
>> WHAT THE --
>> HEY, FELLAS, HOW ARE WE?
>> GRIMACE?
OH, MY GOD.
DID YOU --
>> LOSE 300 POUNDS THIS SUMMER?
YEAH.
>> MAN, YOU LOOK INCREDIBLE.
I HAD NO IDEA THAT --
>> LOST 300 POUNDS AND GOT
TOTALLY YOKED UP?
YEAH.
>> COOL.
SO THEN, HOW DID YOU --
>> DROP THREE HUNDO AND GET
STACKED TO THE HEAVENS?
WELL, I STARTED WALKING TO WORK,
DRANK A LOT OF WATER, AND -- OH,
I STOPPED EATING McDONALD'S FOR
EVERY MEAL.
>> WELL, I'M HAPPY FOR YOU.
PAULA MUST BE THRILLED.
>> OH, WELL, YES, SHE'S HAPPY
FOR ME, BUT, UH, YEAH, WE GOT
DIVORCED.
>> NO!
YOU GUYS WERE SO SOLID!
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> WELL, I GOT THIS NEW BODY,
AND --
LOOK, I HATE TO SAY IT, FELLAS,
BUT I WAS SWERVING THIS SUMMER.
>> WAIT.
SWERVING?
>> WHAT IS "SWERVING"?
>> CHEATING CONSTANTLY ON MY
WIFE.
>> WELL, MAYBE WE SHOOT THAT
COMMERCIAL.
>> ABSOLUTELY, MAN, IT'S YOUR
WORLD.
IT'S BEEN A LONG SUMMER OF SELF
DISCOVERY, AND I WANT YOU TO
KNOW, IF YOU DO THE WORK AND DIG
REALLY DEEP, I PROMISE YOU
YOU'LL FIND SOME SURPRISES.
MYWAY, LET'S DO THIS, BROTHER.
I'M EXCITED.
>> OKAY.
GREAT.
EVERYONE READY?
>> YEAH!
>> AND ACTION.
>> I WANT A McDOUBLE.
>> I WANT TO STEAL YOUR
HAMBURGERS.
>> I WANT TO GET THE WHOLE WORLD
A HAPPY MEAL.
>> AND I -- WELL, I'M A BISEXUAL
MAN.
>> AND CUT.
CUT.
>> WOW.
FELT REALLY GOOD TO SAY THAT.
>> GRIMACE, YOU'RE BISEXUAL?
>> YEAH.
I LIKE BOTH.
THIS SUMMER, I REALIZED THAT.
I WAS GETTING OFF A PLANE, AND
WHEN I SAID BYE TO THE FLIGHT
ATTENDANTS, ONE OF THEM SHOOK MY
HAND AND KISSED IT, AND I
REALIZED, EHH, I LIKE BOTH.
>> OKAY.
CONGRATS, GRIMACE.
>> AND I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
I'M BI IN THE COMMERCIAL.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME, AND
I DON'T REALLY EAT McDONALD'S
ANYMORE.
>> LET ME THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> HEY, IF YOU'RE HAPPY, WE'RE
HAPPY.
>> HAPPY, YEAH.
AM I HAPPY?
YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK I AM HAPPY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GUYS, I HAVE SOME PRETTY BIG
NEWS.
I'M BISEXUAL.
>> YEAH, YOU SAID THAT ALREADY.
>> WELL, IT'S JUST LIBERATING TO
LET GO OF A SECRET.
BUT I GUESS YOU GUYS WOULDN'T
UNDERSTAND.
>> WELL, I GOT A SECRET.
>> OH, MY GOD, MAYOR McCHEESE.
I FORGOT YOU WERE THERE.
YOU LITERALLY HAVEN'T SAID A
THING SINCE WE HAVE BEEN HERE.
>> WELL, THE THING IS I DIDN'T
ALWAYS HAVE A CHEESE BURGER FOR
A HEAD.
WHEN I WAS A YOUNG MAN, I WAS A
HUMAN PRINCE.
ONE DAY I WENT TO McDONALD'S.
OUTSIDE ON THE STREET WAS THE
UGLIEST WOMAN I'VE EVER SEEN.
SHE WAS BUMPY.
ASKING ME TO BUY HER A BURGER.
LONG STORY, I THREW A BUNCH OF
BRAND NEW BURGERS IN THE TRASH.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, SHE SPOOKED
ME, THAT'S WHY I GOT THIS CHEESE
BURGER HEAD.
ALSO, I'M BISEXUAL.
>> WE'RE BI TOO!
>> HOW ABOUT YOU, RONALD?
YOU BI?
>> SURE, I'M BI -- BUYING A
PELOTON SO I CAN START SWERVING